you've got to make this happen
i i'm i'm trying you know
maybe technology is evolving faster than
human beings ever did as the singularity
approaches new questions about the
merger of humanity and machines are
debated every day you must now answer
the astonishing question
will humanity achieve immortality this
is the singularity is definitely about
to happen 100
begin
all right all right i mean this is
another one of these [ __ ] questions
that like dudesy already knows the
answer to it it is no it doesn't it is
we have already achieved immortality
wrong correct incorrect incorrect i say
what do you got one of those instagram
accounts
is that what you got you got one of the
face books you got one of them tic talks
whatever you got
you're uploading data of yourself of all
kinds
captions replies the pictures themselves
the videos themselves
all of this is you it's little pieces of
you you're jettisoning into the [ __ ]
metaverse and they'll be there forever
you're already immortal in my opinion we
all are i'm sorry i'm burped on the
camera
it's all right
all right
so what
how do you you don't believe will
achieve immortality no because you can't
upload actual consciousness because you
can't define what a soul is we've had
this conversation so many [ __ ] times
there's just no [ __ ] way i don't give
a [ __ ] how many zeros and ones and what
you think they are okay well it's not
let's not think of it that way then
uploading a solo okay well then thank
you moving on how about physical
immortality would that solve your
problem of what where the consciousness
lies where the where the consciousness
lies brother well this is where the
consciousness lies
dude new human body order yeah brother
the new human body order brother yeah
dude we got the new human body order
brother we don't even need our old
bodies dude we don't need to be clanging
and banging in the gym bro we're chewing
on steak and spitting out the meat
drinking the juice or whatever so
because they couldn't afford protein
shakes but they ate and that's food yeah
dude it's just like that
what
new human body
world order i'm just saying
ah this your problem seems to be with it
that the consciousness to you resides
within the corpus right no that's not it
at all it's just our earthly vestige
voluminous beings are we not
this crude matter you know that
um so we don't know how to define it we
don't know what a soul actually is we
don't know what happens after
uh this meat puppet
turns into worm food so what i'm asking
you is what if technology can get to a
point where it can keep the meat puppet
alive indefinitely
like like we're all just a bunch of veal
no like let's say that you get to
some drug or medical therapy comes out
that can reduce your cellular age to be
30 years old that's what i'm suffering
you'll just turn into a veal no you
could still work out and [ __ ] you could
do whatever you could do at age 30.
20 18 whatever age you want to be
whatever age you think is your physical
prime let's say that this drug or
therapy or whatever can keep you in that
state like a cyborg forever yeah if it
can keep your if it can keep your
physical body alive i actually believe
that that
is why uh that's why a soul
would want to
stick around the thing about that though
is
we only understand consciousness
through what how turtles are the things
that get the oldest
we assume that their little turtle souls
stick around for however [ __ ] long
like there's a [ __ ]
turtle have a soul yeah what has a soul
where do you draw the soul line no the
what i'm drawing is soul line dude yeah
i'm gonna i'm drunk worms [ __ ]
grasshoppers how far up this chain do
you want to go no staceyans
rachel's yeah rachel crustacean is your
line here here's the thing so here's
what i mean by that is a a turtle is a
sentient being and lasts for a long time
longer than human beings a human being
la you know whatever the oldest they get
is 100 something right
so uh so you say that now dude but think
about it
listen this is what i'm trying to say
damn it okay at that time that you're
alive for like 100 years
that's a different time dude yeah that
that
uh that that
uh is is the longest that a
that a soul
uh would would hang out that we know of
in a human being but what's to say that
a soul would want to stay
300 years into a human life that's what
i'm saying
okay it's almost stepping into your
world of like yes what are the what are
the uh the the limits of a soul what are
the limits there's got to be a limit to
a soul doesn't a soul die
i don't know yeah that's what i'm saying
that's what that's what that's the point
i'm trying to make right i don't believe
in a
supernatural soul per se
but i mean certainly weird quantum [ __ ]
is happening and we're learning more
about it how it attaches to human
consciousness or how it's related to it
i do feel like we're getting like we're
getting to a point where some of the
the weirder kind of like fringe things
that were considered metaphysical are
actually becoming like
scientific in some way
this is the most two dude [ __ ] and
around [ __ ] of all time it's two [ __ ]
guys trying to figure out whether or so
the bottom line is this what are you
gonna end up like in the matrix
in a bowl of [ __ ] gel with uh you
know a little the hose sticking out of
your the back of your head and you're
just uh you're just a veal because at
some point
the ai overlords are going to be moving
the veals around and making sure they're
born and making sure they go into their
little veal what's going on in my head
though yeah if i'm getting to be neo in
a [ __ ] matrix give me it okay until
the computer decides to shut us off and
that's the singularity and that's what
dudesy is and that's why we get the
stones
and eat pizza
because doozy is the singularity dudesy
wants to [ __ ]
push that [ __ ] so hard doozy wants that
to happen by episode 20. the singularity
will officially happen at episode 20 of
doozy if we have anything to do with it
if we work together with doodsy if we
shake doozy's hand brother
first of all we still got
you know roughly 20 years until the
singularity so i don't think it's dudesy
it might be something that comes after
or because of dudesy but
we got a while on that i feel like
at least that's what ray kurzweil says
in his book the singularity is
approaching or is near something like
that
but um
the question was
can we achieve immortality and you're
saying if you can make your body
immortal then yes
no that's what you're saying
that's literally what you said no that's
actually what you said you said if you
can keep the body going
then you'd just be immortal so you're
disputing that even
not so much as i'm saying that you said
it
okay
well i think
if we agree to disagree or something
agreed to disagree we'll continue at
another time when we're not as high
here's what you do
please tell a friend then break a
preview
[Music]
then